[Music]
[Applause]
hey everybody its charlie time to freak
out apparently we're getting a whole
bunch of news about titans Young Justice
Season 3 in this DC streaming service
tomorrow so the teaser implies that
they're going to be revealing a whole
bunch of stuff the biggest questions I
think on everyone's minds is what the
price points are going to be and what
all is going to come with subscriptions
and where is it going to be available
outside of the United States in North
America we've also got a whole bunch of
new flash war stuff that I'll break down
because we learned about five new forces
in the universe including the Speed
Force
so the Speed Force is part of a bunch of
different forces we learned about the
other ones through zooms character in
the events of flash war so if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the DC videos as
the teaser implies we're just getting
started we're gonna be talking about
Titans episodes and Young Justice really
really soon there's also a new round of
that blasts ring giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so first
things first what's going on with the DC
Universe launch I've said before they're
community manager the person that's
actually going to be interacting with
people on this digital platform said
that they're planning on launching it
late August but they just announced all
the comic-con panels for the end of July
you know the DC Universe streaming TV
shows that they're launching this year
the only one that's going to comic-con
are doing a panel that we know of is
going to be Young Justice season 3
they're gonna drop the season 3 trailer
it'll be awesome all freaked out about
it but people are like well if titans is
supposed to premiere before that and
it's supposed to be their big flagship
show why aren't they doing a comic-con
panel words they're something else going
on because the actor that plays Beast
Boy said that he was going to comic-con
he has his cosplay all figured out and
he just posted this picture of a bunch
of behind the scenes pictures that he
took while they were making Titans so
all these books are things that they
handed out to the cast and crew in the
last week like here's something to mark
our first season it's not meant to be
final although it does sound like
they're not getting a season two the
rumor is is that they've been backdoor
renewed for season two and they'll
announce something about that later this
year because they haven't even launched
the service yet what I'm hoping is is
that tomorrow they'll announce what
their plans are to promote the series if
they don't
we make it available like hey surprise
we're letting people sign up and pay for
it now because in addition to titans
Young Justice season 3 Doom Patrol The
Swamp Thing TV show they also have the
back catalog of DC movies and DC TV
shows like the entire Batman catalog of
Batman TV shows is a good example Batman
the Animated Series all the Justice
League cartoons it's supposed to be
their Netflix for DC stuff so of course
there's gonna be a bunch of legacy
content from previous shows and movies
on there but they just haven't released
the official list that's also probably
what we're gonna learn about tomorrow
but we also get comics with that
subscription so if you know Marvel
unlimited or if you've ever used that is
basically like a Netflix for comic books
that Marvel has been doing for the last
several years but up to this point DC
has had no version of that so this is
what that's going to be so in addition
to all the movies and TV shows that
you'll get with this you'll also get
comic books for the price of your
subscription we just don't know how much
is going to cost now I've already done
several videos about what's going on
during Titans all the Jason Todd stuff
all the Robin - Nightwing of a plot the
terror of Trigon Raven the main arc of
season one is supposed to be the
developing of Ravens powers and her arc
as you learn about Trigon then the
progression of dick grace and Robin
leaving Batman and becoming the
Nightwing character we've already seen a
whole bunch of behind the scenes of
Gotham this is what their Gotham looks
like so what I'm hoping is is that they
drop a trailer really soon if they're
gonna be launching the service in August
and they have a plan to or at least
announced a comic-con panel I'm hoping
that they're just gonna slip that in
like oh by the way here's all this
footage because there have been people
that said they saw the pilot episode
months and months ago so there been
episodes that have probably been done
for a while now they just been sitting
on them is you go without saying
whatever they end up dropping tomorrow I
will totally do a video for it but it's
probably gonna be the big info dump
we've been waiting for like just tell me
how much it's gonna cost and when I can
start watching everything recently the
government approved the ATT time-warner
buyout deal
so now AT&T owns Time Warner all the
Warner Brothers stuff they renamed
Warner Brothers Warner Media so
nothing's really gonna change from a
movie or TV show or a comic
books standpoint it's just now they have
a lot more money to play with so it's
really not that big of a deal for them
to throw hundreds of millions of dollars
into this DC streaming service so I
don't think they're gonna be too worried
about the streaming service in the first
couple of years like they can eat losses
if they need to because it does cost a
lot of money to produce television shows
for this getting into flash war stuff so
if you guys didn't know flash Wars been
going on we just had part three in Wally
and Barry just broke the speedforce
order they broke the force barrier as
zoom talks about it so we just found out
about several new forces in addition to
the Speed Force because this big DC
event is happening they're sort of
changing the way the DC Universe works
the source wall that used to protect our
multiverse is now just sort of a barrier
that keeps out this larger space so our
multiverse is just like a bubble on the
outside of this really large dangerous
thing that they're just now revealing as
they're peeling back the layers on the
mythology like here's all these really
cool new aspects to the Speed Force
they have hunter zolomon get Wally to
get Barry to help him break the Speed
Force by teasing him with his children
if you remember Jai and iris west from
the Wally West comics they've been
trapped somewhere else Wally has been
remembering things since DC rebirth so
zoom just teases him oh your children
are stuck in the Speed Force if you
break it it will release them but
surprise he was lying to him so in the
way that the flashes manipulate the
Speed Force to give them great speed
these other forces also control
different aspects of the universe the
first new one he calls the sage force
which has more to do with controlling
people's minds then there's something
called the strength force which is more
about manipulating power and you can see
here you just starts ripping everything
up the sky has been torn open so it's
sort of like the Speed Force served as a
barrier keeping out these other forces
in zoom wanted them to break that so
that it would open the barrier and give
them all these new powers to manipulate
so they work a lot like the Speed Force
works so arguably new DC heroes will
learn to manipulate these forces maybe
Barry Allen the flash too but this is
part of DC Comics deepening the
mythology of the Speed Force and where
the flashes get their powers from
Josh Williamson the writer of this title
also revealed one of the other new
forces that he's going to be unrolling
it's called the still force in Grodd is
gonna be the first one to manipulate it
so think about still force and speed
force and how they sound kind of like
opposites and if Grodd has been obsessed
with the Speed Force for a long time
they just did a big run where Grodd was
trying to steal the Speed Force from
Barry why that might be important but as
part of this flash for it was awesome
there basically racing all over the
earth to go pass gorilla city they run
through Amanda Waller who then calls in
the Justice League Superman isn't fast
enough to catch up because there's
always this funny thing about is
Superman faster than the flash they've
had all those funny races he raced Barry
Allen during the Silver Age he raced
Wally West during the modern age of
comics then right after flash rebirth
when the ginger Wally West came back
there was this moment where Superman is
running next to him and it's sort of
them doing that moment again like haha
remember when we raced before in Wally
says you know all those times we raised
Superman I was actually playing it easy
on you and like even Barry here is
slowly trying to catch Wally but you
remember that the ginger Wally West was
supposed to be the fastest version of
the flash so there's just a moment here
sort of honoring that like he's running
so fast that he's getting ready to turn
into pure energy as Barry tries to get
him to stop before they break things
but of course they break things but it's
really just a tee up this new arc with
zoom where he manipulates all these
different forces that work alongside the
Speed Force what I'm expecting is is
that that DC teaser for all the
streaming service Titans Young Justice
stuff is gonna drop in the morning so
that will probably be my first video of
the day tomorrow I'll name a giveaway
winner when I post that we can all freak
out wondering what all they're going to
announce but what you wait for
everything click here for my
non-spoilery ant-man in the wasp review
and click here for all my Titans and
Young Justice videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight